improvisation is a great tool for actors
and directors it improves morale on the
set because it makes the performers feel
like there are a larger part of the
creative process as they try to find
lines that are better or funnier than
the screenplay but sometimes a noble
attempt to improv cracks up the cast and
leads to an unusable outtake for example
anchorman a laughter free take of this
scene made it into the credits of this
classic retro comedy including a line
Will Ferrell apparently made up on the
spots but that doesn't mean the whole
take was laughter free it comes early in
the movie when one burgundy is
conducting vocal warm-ups and the
minutes leading up to live news
broadcast one is sir ridiculous that
even a pro like Ferrell can handle it
skeleton ran out of shampoo in the
shower the Human Torch could not get a
bank loan the hue the Human Torch was
denied a bank loan and command to while
filming the sequel to 2004 Sankar man
writer director Adam McKay through
outline suggestions on the spa a young
actor Judah Nelson one involving Warmack
wine urine the kid gives it his all but
he can't quite get through it
this is Forte Judd Apatow is a director
that likes to feed him provides lines to
his actors while Billy Joe Armstrong of
Green Day has no problem playing punk
rock in front of thousands of rowdy fans
repeating one of Apatow softer cut jokes
while filming this is 40 made him lose
his composure maybe it hit a little too
close to home I'm really trying to get
back in touch with my anger it's hard to
stay angry when you're
the 40 year old virgin some actors and
directors work together so often that
they develop a rapport that results in
movie magic real-life couple Leslie Mann
and Judd Apatow are definitely on that
list in this clip from the filming of
the 40 year old virgin it's clear that
Apatow treats man like any other actor
providing on-the-spot line suggestions
to improve the scene man is gamer first
but then breaks character when Apatow
crosses a line you would have in the car
so do you want a train wreck LeBron
James is obviously a great basketball
player but who would have thought to be
such a charming and funny actor he holds
his own as a thrifty sensitive version
of himself in trainwreck opposite
formidable comic talents like Amy
Schumer and Bill Hader James roles of
all the improvise lines fed to him
cracking up his co-stars head tortilla
soup I can get a hamburger look how big
I am take a tortilla soup is gonna last
me professor today The Hangover when
your movie stars a veteran of The Office
and The Daily Show and a one-of-a-kind
stand-up comedian it's best to just let
them do their thing in this scene from
the first entry in the hangover trilogy
Ed Helms and Zach Galifianakis engage in
a rapidly escalating war of words
reaching absurd specific and ridiculous
heights look like someone puked here on
your chest you look like someone puked
hair on your face you guys did you see
his body you look like you just
swallowed two frozen turkeys Happy
Thanksgiving
what thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]